also ich sehe das etwas anders als
Bushido in seinem Geheimtipp wo Prozent
erst vorher sehr so ungefähr meint
Schuster bleib bei deinen leisten das
kann ich bis zu einem gewissen Punkt
außer schreiben auftaucht auf der
anderen Seite
Prozent würde man nie raus hin was man
alles kann wenn man sich probiert
deswegen dieser Spruch
vor eintauscht und you can Now du und
dein Büro Intuit
um
wann ist der Mann der über sie selbst
überrascht was man dann doch kann im
Endeffekt man traute sich nur nicht zu
das wiederum dort steht im Gegensatz zu
dem was Bushido unseren Feed
es gibt gewisse Dinge die er bereist
Learning by doing Ernemann
sachlich kamen sie immer wieder tun um
Internetsite kommen dann schafft man das
und das ist unser Geheimtipp an euch